bienvenue dans reporter sur france 24
nouvel épisode aujourd'hui de notre
série sur les frontières du monde ces
points chauds de la géopolitique
direction le lac victoria certaines des
îles de cela qui est le plus grand du
continent africain sont coupées en deux
par la frontière entre l'ouganda et le
kenya frontières qui est le fruit de
récents accords de paix entre les deux
pays qui se disputaient les droits de
pêche des eaux poissonneuses du lac
c'est le cas de l'île de migingo
soumises en quelques sortes à une double
souveraineté et où s'est rendu bastien
renouil avec séverine bardon et olivier
mars
[Musique]
dans les eaux du lac victoria un îlot
plus petits gants terrain de football
voici mig ingo ces barques colorées ses
maisons en tôle ondulée ses 400
habitants essaient de commissariats dans
un exercice de communication un peu
contrats des policiers ougandais et
kenyans partagent un repas et quelques
banalités mais nous essayons ensemble
nous mangeons ensemble et pour tout ce
qui concerne le travail nous échangeons
des informations
officiellement mebe ngo appartient au
kenya mais en 2004 les forces
ougandaises ont débarqué sur l'île et
revendiquer sa possession depuis le sort
de me guy mot empoisonne les relations
entre les deux pays
c'est vraiment défi car je n'ai pas de
réponse
je pense qu'il ya eu un protocole
d'accord qui a été signé entre les deux
états
en 2019 et pour mettre fin aux violences
contre ses citoyens le kenya a
effectivement autorisé la présence de
policiers ougandais sur son territoire
mig ingo vit désormais sous une sorte de
double souveraineté mais cette harmonie
de façade ne parvient pas à masquer le
malaise des policiers kényans
je ne peux pas vraiment vous dire non
pas là cette époque
nous verrons ils nous aident les aides
je ne sais rien à propos du passé
à
[Musique]
tous les jours en début d'après midi
juma et mbaye amène un groupe de
pêcheurs kenyans sur les eaux du lac
victoria est beaucoup
plus que ce bout de terre située à près
de 200 km de ses côtes ce sont les
droits de pêche et le commerce de la
perche du nil qui ont attiré l'ouganda a
mis dix mots
[Musique]
ça la semaine dernière il n'y avait pas
de poisson côté kényan donc c'est pour
ça que les deux derniers jours nous
sommes allés du côté ougandais
m
[Musique]
pour les pêcheurs kenyans la corde 2019
a été bénéfique
en acceptant la présence de policiers
ougandais a mis dix mots le kenya a
obtenu le droit de pêcher en eau gomez
les bateaux kenyan qui traversent la
frontière lacustre ne sont plus
confisquer leurs équipages ne sont plus
battu par les gardes-côtes d'ougandais
seuls ceux qui s'aventurent trop loin
prent encore des risques
des commandes du match
il utilise beaucoup d'essence et vont
loin derrière la frontière
rodarte
et parfois ils rencontrent les forces de
l'ordre qui leur volent le poisson leur
vole leurs affaires
leurs glacières sont renversés dans
l'eau voilà ce à quoi ils font face dans
les eaux profondes
voilà
en août 2000 21 l'un d'entre eux a même
été tué par balles
à plus d'une heure de bateau de migrants
go d'une âge as tu lui aussi ses filets
dans les eaux anglaises mais il reste
dans cette zone un peu floue où les
pêcheurs kenyans sont tolérés ça dépend
des fois vous pouvez déployer un filet
entier ne rien attraper mais demain on
espère revenir avec une bonne pêche
aujourd'hui les bateaux sont revenus
avec un peu de poisson mais demain ça
sera encore mieux est aquazen
si dieu le veut nous espérons péché 50
kg de poissons
cela nous rapporterait environ 150 euros
au moins l'espoir est désormais permis
après des années de conflit le statu quo
entre les deux pays offrent une chance
aux pêcheurs de migingo de retrouver un
niveau de vie décent
nous sommes heureux que les deux pays
aient réussi à signer cet accord
maintenant les ougandais sont nos amis
ils viennent me voir chez nous viennent
au kenya
et nous
si nous n'étions pas aussi occupé à
pêcher nous pourrions aussi aller en
ouganda leur rendre visite c'est pour
entretenir de bonnes relations
mais l'ouganda et loi et la pêche
passent avant tout
amigo en revanche les ougandais sont
nombreux il représente environ un tiers
de la population locale
[Musique]
grace hamadi roues tient l'un des dix
bars de lille
chez moi il y à des pêcheurs et des
policiers ils se détendent après le
travail tout le monde a besoin de se
relaxer
des ougandais des kenyans et je reçois
tous ceux qui veulent venir dans mon bar
je ne fais pas de différence ce n'est
pas un endroit où gandhi qui doit
seulement accueillir des ougandais non
après l'accord de 2010 9,7 jeune
ougandais et venue tenter sa chance à me
jean baud à 12 heures de bateau de son
pays natal
c'est un ami qui m'en a parlé il m'a dit
que c'était un bon endroit où vivre qu'à
partir du moment où vous travaillez dur
il y avait beaucoup d'argent à se faire
ici j'ai donc tenté le coup je suis venu
et je me suis rendu compte que ce qu'il
m'avait dit était vrai
lille a la réputation d'être un petit
eldorado pêcheurs barmaid du marchand
kényan ougandais tous ont choisi migingo
dans l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
grèce avait entendu parler des tensions
qui avait paralysé l'île quelques années
plus tôt elle ne s'attendait pas à
découvrir un endroit facile à vivre un
endroit où kényan ougandais cohabitent
paisiblement même si si le vendeur lui
demande de parler kiswahili pour bien
lui rappeler qu'elle est au kenya je
voudrais 20 schilling de tomates et 20
schilling d'huile
j'ai acheté du poisson et puis je suis
venu ici pour acheter des tomates c'est
facile il ya tellement de magasins et si
l'un d'entre eux n'a pas ce que je veux
je vais dans un autre et je trouve ce
qu'il me faut ensuite je te préparer à
manger à mes enfants et à mes employés
c'est comme dit sur la terre ferme on a
accès à tout
me guide gault et l'île la plus
densément peuplé du monde un concentré
de société multiculturelle pour grace
c'est aussi une terre d'opportunités
grouillante d'activité
c'est moi qui cuisine car mes employés
n'ont pas le temps elles sont toujours
occupés à servir les clients donc je
prends un peu de temps pour leur
préparer à manger ainsi qu'à mes enfants
et à moi même
ce sont comme des soeurs nous venons du
même pays je m'occupe d'elle comme des
soeurs je suis gentil avec elle
la situation inédite de lille est un
atout pour ces femmes expatriées sur une
terre pas tout à fait étrangère
travailler en ouganda serait bien moins
rémunérateurs
pour un ougandais venir ici c'est comme
aller au qatar ou en arabie saoudite
il y a de l'argent
je veux dire mille shillings kényans si
vous les convertissent et emmené aux
gants days cela fait beaucoup d'argent
c'est pour ça que la plupart des
hollandais veulent travailler ici
pour les kenyans aussi lille et
attractive plus proche des zones de
pêche ils font des économies d'essence
et il profite des marchandises
ougandaise à bas prix
[Musique]
au petit matin les pêcheurs sont de
retour à midi ngo zuma et ses hommes
sont parmi les derniers à regagner l'île
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la météo était bonne on a pu
bien pêcher et nous sommes revenus avec
20 à 50 kg de poissons par battre
[Musique]
sa coulpe
la pêche a rapporté la somme espérée
l'équivalent de 150 euros le poisson
sera expédié vers le kenya à 50 km de là
ils auraient aussi bien pu partir vers
l'ouganda
ami guy ngo les douaniers n'ont pas
droit de cité
on ne peut pas vraiment dire qu'on est
au kenya cet endroit est dans les mains
de deux gouvernements il ya des
policiers ougandais et kenyans mais
personne ne nous dit vers quel pays nous
devons nous tourner
mais tant que son activité prospère juma
se soucient peu de ces considérations
politiques
libanaises ainsi c'est chez moi
je loue quatre maisons environ 15 euros
chacune quel amour c étant donnée
l'endroit où l'on vit et les conditions
ici pour des maisons en tôle c'est un
bon prix
c'est enfin manette
une baraque en tôle une table basse de
lit l'endroit est spartiate mais joumana
me demande pas plus
oui c'est je suis heureux d'habiter ici
grâce à cela je peux envoyer mes enfants
à l'école
je gagne de quoi faire vivre mes faibles
c'est à cause de cet argent que nous
sommes tous restés debout malgré les
difficultés auxquelles on a dû faire
face le harcèlement les violences ça
valait le coup
le kenya pndd on n'a pas attaqué aux
unions balle gries aimerait bien elle
aussi continuer à profiter de l'argent
de me guide gault mais aujourd'hui elle
a une annonce à faire à son fils ils
quitteront bientôt lille pour retourner
dans leur village le moment est venu
d'aller à l'école
habitant à ton avis par où va-t-on
rentrée par là qu'on va venir nous
chercher on prendra un petit bateau et
on ira jusqu'en mai gandin
mais
je n'avais personne à qui il confiait en
ouganda je n'ai ni mère ni perd donc les
amener ici
en avril je partir avec lui comme ça il
pourra participer au deuxième trimestre
je suis un peu triste de retourner là
bas la vie est plus difficile quand je
suis ici j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut mais
la barre ce sera plus dur ce sera un peu
très dur
saby trad ses habitudes et les rades
grèce sera vite remplacé à la tête de
son bar kényan ougandais nombreux sont
ceux qui rêvent de faire fortune à midi
ngo quel que soit le statut de l'île
[Musique]
et voilà pour cette frontière lacustres
du lac victoria la semaine prochaine
nous continuerons à explorer les
frontières du monde nous irons en asie à
la frontière du laos et de la chine une
ligne de chemin de fer récemment
inauguré permet de franchir désormais
facilement c'est la fin de ce magazine
on se retrouve donc la semaine prochaine
sur france 24
[Musique]